Jordan,
great to chat with you today.
Hey,
thanks for the invitation.
Yeah.
As we were saying,
just before we started,
it's nice to finally see you and talk to you.
We've been in touch for a while and published a paper on creativity and I should
give you even further context,
which I never gave you when we were actually collaborating,
which is as I was working on my dissertation,
I drove a lot on your work.
I drew a lot on your work on creativity and personality and I thought there'd be
no better place than to start with our discussion.
Then some of that seminal work you have done on creativity and one concept that
really fascinated me in Grad school was the idea of latent inhibition
and
you had done some work on that and had found this really interesting link
between latent inhibition and the personality trait,
openness to experience,
and then you did this,
you did that with Shelly Carson and then you did this work linking it to
creative achievement.
So you could talk a little about what is leading the mission and and how is it
related to creativity?
Well,
a lot of what we learn,
you know,
you might think that you learn what things mean.
Okay,
and there is some truth in that,
but it's more accurate.
Many ways to reverse that,
like reversing so many things in psychology is useful.
It's not that useful to try to figure out why people get addicted,
for example.
It's very useful to figure out why some people,
but most people aren't addicted all the time.
It's not that difficult to figure out why people are afraid.
What's hard is to understand why people aren't afraid all the time.
So a lot of things in psychology,
we get backwards and we tend to think that we learned the meaning of things,
but that's not exactly true.
It's more reasonable to point out that we learned that things are irrelevant,
they start out meaningful and we learned that there were irrelevant and the
reason for that is that when you first encountered something,
you don't want to assume that it's irrelevant mostly because it might be
dangerous.
Partly also because it might be useful,
but most of the things that we encounter,
proof neither be dangerous nor useful and so that we can safely put them aside
with all the other things that we don't attend to and we don't attend to almost
everything,
so learned irrelevance is unbelievably important and latent inhibition is in
some sense a way of measuring how fast someone can make something irrelevant
through learning.
So imagine that something surprises you and you have a big response to it,
but nothing comes of it and then the next time it pops up,
it doesn't surprise you at all.
That's basically learning through latent inhibition.
Now,
one of the things we started to contemplate,
this was back 20 years ago with my student,
Shelly Carson and Daniel Higgins,
was the role that artists play in revivifying perception.
So if you look at a van Gogh painting of viruses,
for example,
or sunflowers,
very famous paintings as if the artist makes you recall how those remarkable
phenomena manifest themselves so that you can see them as if you're seeing them
again for the first time.
And what we thought was that perhaps what the artist was doing was stripping
away your latent inhibition so that you could see things the way you saw them
the first time in all their splendor and glory before you pack them away
conceptually as irrelevant.
And so we tested that with creative people and found that creative people did
have lower latent inhibition and sorted people high in the personality trait.
Openness.
I love that.
I should say that hands.
Isaac got there first.
Curses soul.
It got everywhere.
He did.
William James Williams has got everywhere for us,
but he,
in terms of personality,
I think got their first yet.
Well will you?
It's funny,
I guess in some sense William James even got there before Isaac because he
played around with nitrous oxide,
right?
So he was one.
He was one of the first experiment centers with hallucinogens fundamentally.
And he wrote hippie poetry on nitric oxide,
noting what was likely something like the stripping away of latent inhibition as
a consequence of,
of hallucinogenic use.
So yeah,
and we're all the eldest Huxley of course,
to believe that hallucinogens in particular clean the doors of perception using
William Blake's terminology so that it was possible to see everything as if you
were seeing it for the first time.
There's some forms of brain damage that can produce that too.
So anyways,
yeah,
yeah.
So we tested it.
Well,
it turned out that latent inhibition does look like low latent inhibition.
It looks like it's a importantly related to creativity and to trade openness.
Abraham Maslow,
he talked about newness of appreciation as one of the main characteristics of
self actualizing people and I think that that can be linked to latent
inhibition.
I am sure you would agree.
I bless you just described,
you know,
kind of everything is you kind of wander to the world.
There's a wonder everything is kind of fresh again.
Yeah.
The cost is likely.
Something like cognitive overload.
One of the things does,
Shelly Carson and I,
we're trying to investigate when we studied the hi openness people at Harvard to
high openness students,
which was very good place to study.
That was that.
It looks like in order to handle the excess sensory input of low latent
inhibition,
it's really useful to have very high,
well probably high Iq,
but an high working memory.
Those two concepts are quite overlapping,
so it's difficult to distinguish between them,
but it seems probable that if you're prone to be overwhelmed by sensory
information that you need the cognitive capacity to handle that and also perhaps
the,
and we don't know about this yet,
but the personality ability to sort through that critically so you don't end up
overwhelmed.
So the shared vulnerability model of your student,
Shelly Carson is very relevant here,
right?
I don't know.
Do you know about.
I haven't kept up so well in the last couple of years with the recent work
detailing out the shared vulnerability models.
Shelly and I wrote a joint series of articles for the Canadian Journal of
Psychiatry on shared vulnerability between a openness and predisposition to
schizophrenia.
I mean that's always lurking in the background when you talk about creativity,
right?
The share the overlap with manic depressive disorder and potentially with
schizophrenia.
I don't think that's ever been sorted out properly.
I've written a couple of papers in the past five years on the genetics of
psychosis and it's overlapped with creativity,
which is a fascinating,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of recent research on the genetics of this stuff and showing this
overlap and it seems to be particularly associate with this openness that things
really opens and things related to the default network.
So I think the discovery of the default mode network in recent years has really
allowed us to understand this.
So my colleagues and I published a paper recently showing a direct link between
the efficiency of the default mode network and the personality trait.
Openness to experience.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
So we can now link,
we can link,
you know,
the brain structure and network dynamics.
Okay.
So we used a network approach to look at the connectivity of the default network
and actually analyze individual differences in the connectivity between people
within the default network.
So as a measure of your efficiency within that particular brain network as a
start.
And that was correlated with the openness to experience domain.
So what does that mean in increased connectivity within the default network?
Was associated with.
Okay,
and what did the increased conductivity signify?
What do you think the functional significance of that is?
I think efficiency in the sense of quicker information flow between the three
major sub hubs of the default mode network is the three sub networks that
default mode network involved,
the meaning making meaning making seems to be a huge part of this network.
You know,
the construction of self.
People who get kind of this network knocked out,
they don't even know who they are anymore and I find that fascinating.
And then there's the mental simulation part,
being able to imagine the future.
That's why I've called this network,
like the imagination network to be sexier about it because I think default mode
is.
It connotes that it's kind of a passive network when it's actually a really
active network.
Do you know what I mean?
Like it's not like A.
Yeah,
it does sound like it.
It does make it sound like it's passive.
Hey,
did you see the work done with suicide?
Been showing radical increase in brain connectivity under the influence of
suicide?
Yeah.
I love that and I think we're on the verge of something really integrated.
Jordan [inaudible],
like you wrote that paper with Rachel Aggretsuko Plant and Collin,
you mapped out the whole terrain.
I love that because we've been building off that.
You could send you a paper where we had a synthesis of the whole literature.
We have this hierarchical model of the cognitive exploration domain where you
have like cognitive exploration at the top and then you have openness and an
intellect,
which is the paper where we showed openness until like differentially predict
creative achievement,
but then under that you find all sorts of fastest which contradict which are
negatively correlated with each other.
Even though one step higher in the hierarchy,
they're positively correlated.
Right?
It seems to be going on there,
right?
Is that there are these breed of humans that can take these contradictory modes
of thought within themselves.
You know,
most people,
the general population of all these sorts of the economy is you're either
selfish or you're not selfish.
You're either compassionate or you're not.
You're either,
but it seems like credit people are amazing at able to like harness these
seemingly contradictory modes of being and well,
you know,
I,
it's probably a neat process of neoteny,
you know,
I think that the creative people stay immature.
I love that.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
there's a proclivity in evolution for creatures to evolve towards there
neotenous forum.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
and it looks to me like the creative types are,
they're sustaining that plasticity they have is really early children.
Maybe they are permanently law to some degree into that pretend play mode.
Okay.
That's so characteristic of children between the age of four and say,
well maybe 11,
something like that.
Well,
it's good to have both those things operating,
you know,
because often you talk to people.
This is really characteristic of people who are sort of on the new age end of
the spectrum.
Carl Jung said something interesting once about how people think.
He said for most people a thought appears in their mind and they just accepted
uncritically.
Hmm.
So that's the thinking and.
But that's not really thinking that would be more associated perhaps with what
you described as activation of this imagination network,
but it's a lot more difficult to have the thoughts appear and then to take them
apart and I think it would be really worthwhile to analyze the role of,
well we know Iq is important in that obviously because Iq just enables you to
handle a large number of variables.
Hey,
did you find out if that increased activity that you were describing was
positively associated with Iq?
Okay.
I'm so glad you asked that because I was going to tell you about the follow up
paper and by the way,
I want to be totally fair to my collaborators.
This was led by Roger bed.
I ran something with Martin Seligman the last four years at Penn called the
imagination institute and as part of that we put out a,
a huge grant for people to do research.
So we funded some of this research and I was a coauthor and some of these
papers,
but Roger bd did a lot of this work.
Now with that out of the way,
the follow up paper showed that increased connectivity between the executive
network and the default mode network was essential for creative thinking,
so openness to experience is not equivalent to creative thinking.
Right,
so that's the kind of one step is to show there's a link between the imagination
network,
an openness,
but really real novel and meaningful creative cognition seem to require that
both the default mode network and executive network executive tension and the
salients network.
Actually the salience network is an interesting network.
We could talk about the interaction between those two networks were essential
for the cognition to be novel and meaningful.
That's fascinating because most people in the general population that santee
correlated,
some of these networks are anti-correlated like most people.
For most people it's like as soon as you focus on the outside world,
you shut up your imagination or when you go home,
imagine.
Yeah,
but creative people who are really creative,
they're like a good at keeping on call.
That really is interesting because shelly and I,
back when we were doing the creative achievement questionnaire research,
we kind of thought that one of the things that might characterize creative
people is that ability to switch back and forth between openness and critical
thinking was under voluntary control
suggested.
I think to the extent to which it's under voluntary control.
I wonder how I could study that.
Like we just know that this is what the brain networks are doing.
They're toggling back and forth,
but could we ask,
could we do a report?
It's almost with a sense that like creative people,
as soon as you ask them to think about it,
if they're in the flow state,
then suddenly evaporates.
You know?
It's like,
yeah,
we'll need to.
It's hard to tell how much.
Okay,
so.
Well,
and of course defining voluntary scientifically is not a straightforward thing,
but it'd be interesting to see if people do think about that is voluntary and if
it's a skill as well.
If it's something that people can learn to develop because you can to some
degree,
teach people critical thinking like you can teach them to look at an idea and
break it apart and analyze it,
so all that remains to be determined,
I guess.
Hi everyone.
I just wanted to take this moment to thank you for your support of this podcast
over the years.
It's been a lot of fun doing this podcast for over the past three years.
If you'd like to further support the podcast,
I wanted to let you know a few things you could do to make it a better
experience for you all.
First,
I'd really appreciate it.
If you could subscribe to the show in itunes.
This will help make the show more prominent and itunes and increase our
listenership.
I believe you can describe both on your phone and on your computer.
Second,
it'd be great if you could give the show a rating and review in itunes.
I definitely read all the reviews.
Another thing you can do is donate some money to the show,
like under the psychology podcast.com and clicking on the link support the
podcast at the bottom of the page.
That's the psychology podcast.com.
Some of you had been noting that the audio quality was less than optimal thanks
to the donations that we've been receiving.
I'm really excited to announce that in the next couple of weeks we're gonna have
a completely revamped audio structure to the show and you should notice a huge
improvement in the audio quality.
Thanks for your patience with that.
Thank you for your support of the show over the years.
It's been a real labor of love for me.
Okay.
Back to the show.
So let's move onto some other topics.
You did this really interesting study that I read,
you know I wrote about inside of America with Christine Brophy on the
personality of credits we found we were logging well,
two things we wanted to establish.
The first is we wanted to establish if there was a coherent group of political
beliefs and attitudes.
Let's say that you could bring under the rubric of political correctness,
you know,
because of course you know that just because a concept pops up in the popular
literature,
let's say,
or often even in the psychological literature,
that doesn't mean that the concept has any basis.
In fact,
what we did was we did a standard psychometric investigation and so we
oversampled the politically correct attitude domain.
We had a bunch of people come up with questions that seemed to be indicative of
what people were describing when they discuss political correctness in the media
and we put together I think 400 questions and had a very large number of people
answer all of them and then subjected the question.
The answer is two,
a factor analysis and came up with a coherent two factor solution to political
correctness.
One that looked like it was associated with what you might describe as the
radical left,
the interventionist radical left and the other that was more associated with,
I would say just left leaning and then looked at the personality predictors and
personality and cognitive predictors of.
Of both of those,
they weren't.
That highly correlated.
Interestingly enough,
I mean that was partly because we used to extraction technique that decreased
the correlations,
but you could,
you could extract are two quite separate sets of political belief and yeah,
trait.
Agreeableness was a good predictor,
which was quite interesting because it hadn't showed up that power trait,
agreeableness and being female as well,
which was also quite interesting.
We're in a situation now way where it isn't obvious how men and women are going
to cooperate politically because it does look like our differences are intrinsic
differences in personality and interest might divide us quite radically
politically and so god only knows how that's gonna play out on the political
realm.
Yeah.
It's really interesting to think about and I.
I've been trying to wrap my head around the real practical implications when I
look at the data and then try it.
Like I'd like to hear your thoughts on what you think the percentage of this
could really be impactful.
So like I look at a figure the other day of the overlap of the distribution and
compassion and there is in the general population,
we're not talking about like it's a totally different plan,
you know,
70 percent overlap and the bfs that you cocreated with Colin,
but,
and so in that paper recalling looked at the gender differences and the
different big 10 compassion did have the largest gender difference.
But if you look at the actual graph,
you know,
you see like 70 percent and of course it doesn't say anything about at the
extremes.
This is something that people really don't understand.
And social scientists don't understand that well either.
Although we should.
Like there's two things that were not trained well I think in social scientists.
One is consideration of the tails because the tails have disproportionate impact
on behavior and on political and economic outcomes.
And then the other is the distribution problem because most of us are taught
that almost everything is normally distributed and that actually turns out
there's a lot of important exceptions to that,
including creative achievement.
It's not normally distributed at all.
It's just standard.
Frito distributed probably be small differences at the average level and then
walloping differences at the extreme and then it's the differences at the
extreme that determined behavior.
So for example,
no,
there's good evidence that the difference between men and women with regards to
interest in people versus things is about one standard deviation,
which is the largest psychometric difference between the genders.
That's been reported as far as I know.
And so then you think,
well,
okay,
it still means that men and women overlapped to a large degree.
But if you look at what determined someone's decision,
for example,
to go into a field like engineering,
you probably have to be.
I wouldn't think what percentage of the population are engineers.
I bet it's no more than two percent.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
so let's say one in 50,
maybe it's one in 25,
but whatever.
It's something like that.
Five percent of the population.
So let's say to be an engineer,
well you have to have a high Iq and you have to be conscientious,
but then you have be interested in things,
but you don't have to be just a little bit interested in things.
You have to be really interested in things and even if the okay average
difference between men and women is only one standard deviation,
which is still a comparatively large,
that could mean that virtually everybody who's really interested in things ends
up being male and that's exactly what you see.
You see about a 15 to one preponderance of male engineers versus female
engineers and you know,
you might say,
well that's socio-cultural and can,
can be ameliorated,
but the evidence doesn't support down at all because those differences maximize
in the Scandinavian countries.
You mind if I just think really interesting.
Okay.
And by the way,
I want to thank you for.
I've lost like 100 of your videos to prepare for this interview.
So like even if I don't always agree with you,
I,
it helps clarify what in the hell I actually believe.
So thank you for being so authentic and your opinions.
I totally believe in quality of opportunity.
Right?
And it seems like what really irks you is when people call for equality of
outcome,
that that's really where you know when you're ready.
Infuriate is a better way.
I know how dangerous it is.
It's unbelievably dangerous.
People have no idea what to messing with when they mess with equality of
outcome.
Well,
and then do you have a nuanced discussion about it,
let's say,
because that's what we should do.
It's like,
okay,
the data indicate more and more strongly that there are significant differences
between men and women in a variety of dimensions and more importantly that those
differences expand as cultures become more egalitarian.
Okay,
so then that opens up an avenue of political questions.
It's like the first political question would be,
the first observation should be,
we better accept that as fact because it actually seems to be grounded in very
serious science and the scientists who discovered this biased in the opposite
direction,
it wasn't what they were happy to find.
No one expected it.
Okay,
but let's take it at face value.
Just for the sake of argument and say,
all right,
now this opens up a minefield of political questions.
The first is,
so for example,
let me take a pro diversity stamps just for a minute,
even though it hurts my heart to do so,
so it looks like if we allowed naturalistic sorting to take place merely as a
consequence of people's express choices,
that all of the elementary school teachers would end up being women.
Yeah,
well it's so,
so it's going to be there and it already is the vast majority of the budget.
If the sorting continues unabated,
that's likely to increase that.
Increasingly it is what it is,
but we don't know what to do about that from a sociopolitical perspective.
Now you know,
hypothetically we could enforce equity of outcome,
equality of outcome,
but it would be extremely costly.
It would require a tyrannical effort on the part of the government and there
would be all sorts of unintended negative consequences.
Now,
those might be consequences that we're willing to bear,
but we don't want to move into this under the presupposition that the
differences.
We're trying to eradicate our only socio-cultural in nature because clearly
they're not and you'd hope that we would get to the point where we could
actually have an intelligent discussion about it.
We don't know what to do about this.
That's the thing,
the proposal,
what to do about it in one of your videos,
the one that I talked about because you actually made a concrete I and one of
the videos I watched you made a very specific argument.
You said,
I think that we should eliminate poverty,
that we should have eliminated unnecessary suffering,
you know,
give everyone a relative sort of baseline of income.
But then after that is the next stage,
we should sort of allow the free market to sort of like allow people to then
express.
So you still stand by that.
Will you send that video about their function of the state?
Well,
I don't know because it's so complicated like I don't,
I certainly don't think that we should rush headlong into the provision of a
universal basic income because the probability that that will have radically
unintended consequences is unbelievably high.
So I think one of the things that would probably do,
especially among unemployed,
hopeless people,
is increase their access to drugs like oxycontin and opiates.
See the problem with the left wing view of improving economic equality is the
left wingers are so obsessed with the economic side of inequality that they
don't pay enough attention to the cultural side of inequality.
So if you're down at the bottom of the economic pyramid,
the fact that you don't have enough money is a big problem,
but it's only one of many serious problems you have.
And I would say an equally serious problem is that you don't have anything
productive,
engaging and meaningful to do with your time.
And the problem with that is that,
you know,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but it's pretty easy to get rats that are isolated in a cage singly to be
addicted to cocaine.
You can do it very rapidly,
but it's almost impossible to get routes in the naturalistic environment
addicted to cocaine.
That's really interesting.
It is.
Yeah.
Well,
there was there.
He followed just slouched behaviorist that studied routes in their natural
environment and they're quite a bit different than the genetically modified
three quarter bodyweight starved single lab rat existing alone in the cage.
Rats are social creatures,
you know?
Yeah.
Well if you were sitting alone in prison,
yeah,
and somebody and offered you an endless access to cocaine,
it's like the probability that you take it is extremely high,
but if you have something better to do then it's low.
The problem we're going to have to deal with is more like provision of
meaningful activity to people who are being displaced by large scale
socioeconomic transformation.
That's not a matter of merely redistributing income.
Do you know the video I'm talking about when you talk about the function of the
state?
Yeah.
I think.
I think I would send a political convention in Canada about five years ago.
I've done work on what are called like.
I've done work on giftedness.
I've been working on kids with learning disabilities.
Trying to.
The equality of opportunity is what I'm playing for.
That's what I'm.
And in terms of aligning it with the science as well,
you know,
it's a beautiful thing me when they are not a post,
when there's the truth and the helping someone or you know,
the same thing,
you know,
that's a beautiful thing,
right?
Yeah.
So
this is an interesting question,
is like what could the function of the state opportunity b too helped her make
sure that there's a quality of individual expression?
I guess that's what we're talking about here.
Well that's written.
That is a fundamental question.
I mean million dollar question.
Yeah.
Well one of the things the state does quite effectively is invest in universally
accessible infrastructure.
So everybody benefits from safe,
clean streets,
right?
And everybody benefits from it on active cultural meal.
You like a city like Montreal is a really good example that is extraordinarily
culturally active.
There's festivals going on there all the time and a lot of them are outside.
A lot of them are free.
Everyone benefits from that.
Education is a good hypothetically,
a good place for the state to invest with regards to equality of opportunity.
Although it disproportionately benefits people who are on the upper end of the
cognitive distribution,
it's hard to escape from that a.
So that's for sure.
Back to the back to the intrinsic difference issue is like we don't really know
what the political impact is of the fact that men and women seem highly likely
to sort themselves out into different occupations if we just allow them free
choice cause no one has thought that no one thought that was what was going to
happen.
You know when the bloody okay,
radical leftists are fighting this like mad because they insist that all these
differences are associate cultural,
but the problem is it doesn't look like they are
all of these politics and fractions,
right?
Individual differences.
What is fits fascinates me.
People are complex systems.
Every one of us is a complex system of lots of personality traits,
motivations,
etc. And you know,
there are people who score high on compassion regardless of whether you're a
male or female.
A lot of ice score.
High question I heard you say you score high on capacity in one of your videos.
You know,
when you went through the bfs,
so it's not like we're saying like,
you know,
you have to be female to be competitive,
which is funny.
With the politically correct research we did,
we did find that a lot of the predictive power,
a lot of what was predicting affiliation with politically correct standpoint was
trait agreeableness,
but being female was an additional predictor and that was really strange because
most of the time,
and I'm sure this is the case with literature that you've investigated as well.
Most of the time if you look at sex differences in a particular outcome,
you can get rid of them by controlling for temperament,
but you could most of them look like we didn't know there was an additional
effect of there was an additional effect.
Sex.
Yeah.
Did you look at politeness versus
passion?
Yes,
we did,
but I can't.
It's been a while since I reviewed the paper and I can't bring it to mind.
Okay.
No,
I think it was driven mostly by compassion,
if I remember correctly.
Yup.
And it makes sense,
you know,
because I think that what's happening on the end of the spectrum,
let's say political views are driven by compassion,
is compassion is primarily a dimension that's there to facilitate intense
relationships between individuals and their dependents.
Which kind of looks to me like what compassion does is that,
so you know,
you have compassion for an infant or you have compassion for someone who's
elderly and unwell.
If you're a very compassionate person,
it's very easy to take the side of the downtrodden and to look for a perpetrator
or cars and lots of time.
That's extremely useful,
right?
If you're taking care of an infant and the infant is in distress,
the first thing you should be doing is scanning the environment for the cause
and eliminating it.
One Answered question is,
well,
what happens when you scale up that personality attribute and it starts to
operate politically?
Here's some.
Here's the thought for you.
Tell me what you think about this.
I think that we have to traits that orient us in the social world.
I think agreeable disorients us in small groups and conscientiousness orients us
in large,
impersonal groups and that the switch point,
the point where you transitioned from an agreeable viewpoint to a conscientious
viewpoint is,
is indeterminate.
Is tHere a sex difference on the conscientiousness are males tire?
No,
you're a little more orderly.
Okay.
And men are a little more into distress.
It does,
yeah.
I was going to ask industrious in particular because roy baumeister made a
similar.
You could link that to roy baumeister's argument and what are men good for?
I think that's the title of the book.
He argues that that's the major sex difference,
that it's not like men or women are better than each other.
It's that like there have been different motivations in terms of how we want to
help people and a lot of men have tended throughout the course of history to
wanting to help,
you know,
like a huge social networks have huge social networks and I wonder if that's a
difference in exactly what you're saying.
Well,
I think it might be.
I think it might.
Look,
human beings are strange.
First of all,
there's no animal warden for conscientiousness.
Yeah.
Oh,
is that right?
I've never seen one.
Oh,
that's so interesting.
You know,
it's funny,
I was chatting with column the other day.
He said that,
um,
they just found a correlation between the salients network and conscientiousness
and that's not really well evolved
in other animals.
That's just interesting.
So look,
if you think about it this way,
if you think that imagine that there's a human niche niche distinguishes us from
animals and I mean obviously there is,
but one of the distinguishing elements is that we can produce groups whose size
exceeds that of our primate cognitive capacity.
So,
you know,
I think it's dunbar's work indicates that with human beings,
our tribes tend to fractionate when they exceed about a group of about 200,
but obviously we can produce groups that are much,
much larger than that that are functional.
But what that means is that those groups have to operate on principles that are
outside of the networks that other primates would use to organize themselves
socially.
And I think that's where conscientiousness kicks in.
Well,
and if you look at what predicts performance in bureaucracies,
it's conscientiousness,
snot agreeableness.
In fact,
agreeableness is slightly correlated negatively with managerial performance and
so,
okay.
I think once a group exceeds the size where it's familiar,
then you have to use a different ethical system to cope with it and that's
conscientiousness and I think one of the problems with what's happening to us
politically right now is that we're trying to implement.
Agreeableness has a political trait and I don't think it functions well in large
groups.
I hear that argument.
I think sometimes some of the things that you are perceiving as relevant to the
agreeableness,
to me it might be actually something different and let me elaborate what I mean.
So I've done some research lately.
I realized that there's no scale of pathological altruism.
It's a construct that barbara oakley has written about,
but I want to do systematic research on this.
I think this is relevant to this conversation,
so I constructed a reliable and valid scale of pathological altruism and it is
negatively correlated with agreeableness and compassion.
We're not talking about it's in that domain.
What did you find were the defining characteristics of pathological altruism?
Okay,
so we looked at grandiose narcissism versus vulnerable narcissism.
I am so fascinated with that distinction.
I don't think vulnerable narcissism has got as much attention in the literature.
We found about point six,
point seven,
correlation between pathological altruism and vulnerable narcissism.
Okay.
Vulnerable narcissism is this,
they called it a psychoanalyst,
got a closet narcism where it's like you have these grandiose fantasies inside
and you have entitlement,
so you score score skyhigh on entitlement.
However you don't present yourself that way.
You present yourself as really vulnerable.
We find that the grandiose narcissism vulnerable,
so they score high on the grandiose fantasies questionnaIre and entitlement
subscale differentiates them,
is trait neuroticism.
That's the thing that differentiates them,
so whereas grandiose narcissism is with much lower in neuroticism,
vulnerable narcissism almost perfectly correlated with high neuroticism,
almost perfectly correlated,
correlated
one of my collaborators who on that paper he wrote another paper with a title.
Vulnerable narcissism is mostly just neuroticism.
We're talking about if you do a structural model,
we're talking literally almost perfectly correlated.
The only thing that additional variants that's explained as some antagonism,
like I said,
entitlement for instance,
it's a subset of highly neurotic people who also have developed a sense of
entitlement,
and assertive,
interpersonal antagonism towards others.
So we're not talking about
you guys are really onto something there.
Great,
great.
Yeah.
I really think so.
I mean the question is whether or not you're just fleshing out neuroticism with
those sorts of correlations or whether you've got a subset of people in there
who have taken neuroticism to the next step.
I don't think it's synonymous with eroticism because most people who present
themselves with high neuroticism to the therapist as you know,
if they are depressed,
not like they have this grandiose fantasy is an entitlement.
Early developmental experiences seems to be a really interesting moderator.
We found.
We found that those who were told that they're worthless and childhood or that
were actually in some sense did experience sort of trauma in their childhood.
That seems to actually correlate with later on.
And I think that from a clinician perspective,
you know,
we want to help these individuals integrate health lena society and I think
maybe that's where your responsibility argument comes into play.
Well the union idea behind that was the,
those grandiose fantasies were compensations,
right?
And that within them,
okaY,
there was the seeds in some sense of the developmental pathway.
So if someone is oppressed and put down continually and they develop competence,
suntory fantasies,
the fantasies are you can think about them as the manifestation of that
imagination network,
trying to lay out an alternative mode of being.
But then those fantasies have to be subject to critical analysis so they don't
become dwelling places or reasons for bitterness in relationship to the world.
We just came full circle in the sense that in a way that started this
discussion,
you know,
like this interplay,
but dynamic interplay between imagination and then rationality and this.
Well,
the problem with those fantasies,
well the problem with those fantasies is that they're not decomposed.
Yeah.
So like if you're dealing with someone that's someone clinically and they have
these fantasies,
then you might think about them as a starting place for how they could more
modified their life.
so the fantasy is saying the fantasy is serving as a counterpart to the painful
reality.
The painful reality is downtrodden,
neuroticism.
The fantasy is as far on the other end of the scale as like it balances the
pathology by putting something on the other end of the scale that's equally far
away.
Then you have to help the person take a critical look at the fantasy and start
to make it a reality instead of just a fantasy and to lay out a strategic plan
for doing that.
Exactly,
exactly.
You know,
I mean look,
we,
we're all human.
Like I personally went through a stage.
I think when I was in my early twenties,
I was so insecure.
Like I wanted it to be like academic.
I wanted to like,
that was my way of proving that I was smart and that wasn't healthy,
you know,
and like I get it.
But I also get,
you know,
the value of when I really decided to take some of these grandiose fantasies I
had of being an academic and I say,
well look,
you know,
I'm going to just take it out of my head and I'm going to like work really
freaking hard.
I mean,
I was in special education as a kid because I didn't auditory disability.
Yeah.
But I was really young at one point.
I just took 100 percent responsibility for that situation.
Okay.
So you took the right route out of that.
They'd have those fantasies,
like you can think of those fantasies as part of the attempt by the,
the mechanism that generates creativity to lay out a pathway forward.
The problem is,
is when people dwell in,
the founder sees and dwell on the fantasies instead of instead of breaking them
down into a strategic plan and realizing them,
which is what a good therapist should help someone with.
Absolutely.
I'm sure you've done that in your practice.
You were in practice over 20 years,
just.
Yep.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also what happens with our future authoring program because what we really
asked people to do in the future authoring program is to generate a competence
satori fantasy.
Right now we say,
well,
he lay out how your life could improved then imagine what your life would be
like if all those improvements took place,
but we don't stop with that.
Okay.
Then we say,
okay,
now subject that to some critical analysis,
decompose it,
make it into a strategic plan,
break it down into things you would do day by day and week by week so they can
become realizable in the world.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean that's so sensible,
right?
I mean it's like,
by the way,
this paper I can send to you,
it's actually under review right now.
We have a whole section on the clinical implications of these findings and
yeah,
I'd like to see it.
Roy baumeister a really interesting book on.
I think it's the best sort of real honest assessment of evil.
Have you read the evil inside human violence and cruelty?
No,
I haven't read it yet.
No.
NoW something.
He talks in there because he wants to get a full understanding of all the causal
forces of what we call evil and something in there he talks about is he makes it
so clear that responsibilities not the same as culpability,
like responsibility at the same thing as bleeding
the situation you just described,
like let's say that you are high in neuroticism and you were subject to bullying
of a real sort and trauma when you were a kid.
Well,
it's not like you're culpable for that.
Correct?
Correct.
You need to take responsibility for it because,
well,
who else is going to.
Right,
but you know,
as a scientist and we want to truly,
truly understand the phenomenon.
We need to understand all of the causal factors and we need to do that as
objectively as possible.
That's not saying that we're not allowed to have compassion.
Like I have immense compassion want to make the world a better place.
I know you want to make the world a better place as well,
but I think I can like kind of separate those things at different times and then
try to kind of thoughtfully think through how we can integrate this.
Yeah,
I'd like to see the paper.
I'm very interested in what you're doing.
I'd like to see both of them.
The one on the default network.
Yeah,
and also the one on on vulnerable narcissism.
I really do think that's associated with the sorts of things that I've been
talking about.
Relationship to the school shooters for example,
because they develop grandiose competence,
suntory fantasies,
and then act them out the most pathological way.
Solely relevant.
Yeah.
Good talking with you.
Good talking to you.
Thanks for your time.
Yep.
And then let me know when this goes up and I'll tweet it and all of that.
Sounds good.
Have a good day.
Okay.
Okay,
see ya.
Bye.